first of all congratulations on this
series and already getting a season two
before it even debuts
how does yeah that was great that was
that was some good news that's for sure
i'm sure as an actor it's very good news
yeah it's nice to have job security
how does the level of excitement around
this series feel has it sunk it in or do
you feel like you're still in your
little bubble since it hasn't actually
even premiered yet
yeah i was just talking to rosamund
about that it's it's a strange feeling
it's coming in waves um
it kind of feels like
i guess having a i don't have any
children but maybe having a child and
and just uh you know watching it grow to
a certain extent and now letting it go
to its first day of school or something
um we're very protective of it we feel
like we've been in a vacuum for a while
and now it's slowly starting to get out
and it kind of feels like everything's
hitting
fast forward now which is exciting and
fun uh
scary at times but uh we're ready we've
been doing it for a while and
with covet and everything there's been a
lot of obstacles and challenges but
we're very proud how much everyone has
stuck together and how it's turned out
so i think we're all ready
what was the whole initial process like
did you go through a whole audition
process did you get to meet rosamund at
some point like how did that because
your relationship especially is so
important to the show
yeah it was it was very unique i i
didn't go through an audition process um
i had a very long chat with rafe
i'd met him previously
um i think doing some sort of test
reading years ago for another show and
we'd cross paths
and so he remembered me and i think he
had me in mind possibly for lan
and then uh it was
it was just a process of a few
conversations with him and then all of a
sudden i was on a facetime with rosamund
and of course she's producing the show
as well so it was important for her to
to talk to me and to meet me because we
have such a dynamic relationship in the
show
and so that turned into about a
three-hour conversation about
life and all sort of likes was like
existential things and and religion and
career and family and
it was really just to get to know and uh
we hit it off uh a hundred percent and
then
a few days later it was uh it was mine
and uh so i had a i was standing by uh
this beautiful lake in michigan
and i got the i got the word
and i
i did a little dance by the lake and i
kind of screamed because i wanted it so
badly so so badly i wanted it and for so
many reasons
and uh that was it and a few weeks later
and my bags were packed and i was headed
to the czech republic
what was the top reason for you was it
something about the character was it
something about the genre what what did
you feel drawn to because it's easy as a
viewer to see why it would be so
appealing but what was it like for you
well
you know
first of all growing up in the states in
a very small town
being asian american
you know i grew up sort of watching
fantasy shows with
you know with certain people cast in
certain roles and and and i just never
thought that as i as i got older and got
into acting that i'd i'd have a chance
to play something like lan um to play
a king
or an uncrowned king um
to speak in an english
accent and to
to protect someone as amazing as
rosamond and just to have this
incredible role of strength and
honor and loyalty and with an amazing
back story and
i just i i didn't know that it was ever
going to be possible for me to to be uh
to be given a role like this and when it
came true it was very surreal
um
a funny story is that i do this kind of
vision boarding thing uh for my career
and
i'd saved the cover uh to the eye of the
world on my phone in 2011 and i didn't
know
much about the wheel of time but i just
thought i loved the look of the cover
and the characters and i thought that it
was something that i would love to do
one day and here i am
10 years later playing lamb
so you willed it into existence before
you even knew you were it's so crazy it
didn't take me too long to pull it up
but it's true and i just showed roz uh
like three weeks ago i showed her the
picture she couldn't believe it
with a character like this because he is
a bit mysterious in the beginning and we
he's not a man of many words we only
sort of get things out of him when he
has to
so what was your way into him for you
did you read the books did you do some
other type of research how did you key
into who he is
i mean the wonderful thing about the
wheel of time is that there's there's so
much out there right there's so much to
to dig into um i did immediately jump
into the books
um
and
i read up to
the dragon reborn and then went back to
new springs i knew that was really
important for
the relationship between land and
moraine and sort of how they began
um
but what really
helped me
it's kind of how i work as an actor is
going from outside in and
was just getting as soon as i got to
prague
i
started rehearsing stunts for this
what is now the winter night action
sequence and it took me a month
to get
into that and
that was such a wonderful way in
to land
how he moves
um
just how
skilled he is with that sword and
it just it really helped inform me when
i you know it's
when i played agent zero on x-men um the
first thing i did was was get his boots
and walk around this small town in
queenstown uh new zealand
so that's i kind of like to work from a
physical standpoint so having that time
with the with the stunt guys
choreographing this amazing scene was
everything to me and from from then on i
felt very comfortable
what was it like to shoot that whole
sequence because
that's such an interesting sequence it
starts with celebration and dance and i
i was watching it thinking god i'd want
to you know go party in this town and
then all of these horrible creatures
show up and
gross grotesque murder happened
and i was like oh maybe i i won't go
visit
but what was that like to shoot all of
that it seems like it must have been
really elaborate what was most important
as far as getting it right
repetition um i was lucky to have uh
at least a month with the stunt team
prior when they first showed me
the breakdown of what we're going to do
the some guys
stop men and women they come up with
sort of a breakdown of what it's going
to be and they shoot a full video on
their iphones and they cut it and they
put music to it so
when they showed me that first cut i
thought for the first time in my career
i i may not be able to do this this was
150 beats
it was incredibly long intricate complex
i mean there was so much to it and so it
was just
repetition over and over and over
and getting it right and then applying
that once we got set
there on this on the amazing two rivers
set and
we have
such an amazing art department here they
created this world for us to work within
and so
everything you see in the winter night
sequence is real for the most part i
mean
we're reacting to everything from the
from the drops of the snow to the dust
to everything the scene where i kind of
run and cover rosamund
that's a real scene they shot five
massive dust cannons and i had to run
through the dust and cover her so it's
all practical and uh
yeah it just felt very real to answer
your question uh yeah the acting came
kind of second
well what would you say to tease his
journey this season how much will he be
affected and changed by what happens
land's journey
um all i can say from an actor's
perspective is that it's been the most
challenging thing i've ever done in my
life
because playing someone that is that
silent quiet whatever you like stoic
strong
it is a man a few words but the writers
have have really done a wonderful job at
creating these these emotional scenes
for him as well that the the fans can
look forward to you really get to see a
side of land that for me as an actor
we're scary to try because i know how
beloved he is
and when i read the scripts the first
time especially five and and six you
know it's i just thought how am i going
to do this
and uh
you know now in hindsight i i think we
did a a pretty good job but uh it's been
a very very diverse journey with him
emotionally and uh i can't wait for fans
to watch it
well it's so epic and impressive and i
appreciate you talking to me about it i
i'm excited to see more well thank you
very much
thank you
you